there is no long-lived population on
Earth for whom which seed oils make up a
significant calorie contributor you
might not believe that these oils are
harmful to you and you know I'm always
willing to adjust my stance when new
data presents itself but there's no
reason to consume them
Max lugavia welcome to the show Chris
honor to be here thanks for having me
look at you fresh from the dentist it's
a smiley dude I chipped a back tooth on
a cacao nib
the irony it's a superfood and it was
super effective at chipping a uh a tooth
in the back of my mouth
what was that thing that you shared a
little while ago that had like frosted
Shredded Wheat as the greatest superfood
on the planet take me through that yeah
so that was something that was published
by Tufts University the Friedman School
of nutrition over there
um there's great uh interest in
developing what's called uh nutrient
profiling system among scientists and uh
ultimately to be used for the public
good and so the food Compass which was
Tufts is tuft's sort of best take on
what uh what an idealized nutrient
profiling system would look like
uh came out and um it had all of these
various different food items ranked the
the supplementary material that came
with the paper was I don't know it was
like a couple it was like 100 pages long
or something like that and um it ranked
every possible food in the supermarket
and
basically the the the the reason why
it's in the why ultimately it's in the
Public's interest to create a food
profiling system like this is because
the public is confused right about
nutrition the public doesn't know what
to eat right for decades we were told
via the USDA food pyramid to load up on
something like 7 to 11 6 to 11 servings
of grains per day right and that's been
replaced by the my play Paradigm with
which still implores us at every meal to
include grains to utilize vegetable oils
and things like that so the public is
confused right
and so
uh Tufts University thought that it was
in The public's interest to create this
this food profiling system called the
food compass and um it had a lot a lot
of flaws that were illustrated by a
separate group headed up by a researcher
named tybile
who teased out various food items and
put them on a hierarchy so this was not
an extrapolation this was Data taken
from the supplementary material provided
with the food Compass paper and it
showed these completely asinine
relationships between various foods that
even a four-year-old would say this is
absurd right it ranked Frosted Mini
Wheats above a poached egg for example
it put ground beef at the bottom of the
of the chart for the most part
um and it was just completely absurd
right it ranked
eggs substitute fried and vegetable oil
above actual egg
which you know eggs ground beef Dairy
these are some of our most nutrient
dense foods and so this chart went viral
which was basically a chart that was
created by this separate group that
published a reaction critique to the
food Compass paper which by the way went
completely ignored by the Journal that
it was submitted to and also ignored by
Tufts
just to show the Ridiculousness of of
this food compass and really you know
again I don't think that it was like
created out of malicious intent but uh
it it completely
underweighted foods for uh their the
nature of their processing so it
basically didn't penalize Foods
appropriately for being Ultra processed
which we know are a contributing factor
to the Obesity epidemic and the obese
the epidemic of chronic disease foods
that are Ultra processed now make up 60
of the calories that your average
American consumes every single day so
it's a major problem we know that that
only 10 percent of Americans have good
metabolic Health the rest are struggling
with some type of metabolic illness
manifest as either dysregulated lipids
or an oversized waistline or what have
you and so you know you you fail to
penalize Ultra processed foods which
Americans are already over consuming you
don't properly credit foods for
containing protein which is a very
important
macronutrient or dietary fiber I think
actually protein and fiber were given
the same weight and they were both
underweighted relative to other
um uh features so yeah so it was a mess
it was just a complete mess and they've
since um I've actually had a
conversation with uh Darry who's the the
lead researcher behind it and you know
we just we have different views on I
think the value of protein
um but you know at this point I've
communicated and I've done you know I've
written three books and I've uh had many
protein experts on the podcast and I
think protein is is incredibly important
and so um you know I think it's it's
kind of odd that we have such Divergent
viewpoints on that
um and you know
again I think I think there is value in
in creating a nutrient profiling system
but that ain't it the food Compass ain't
it
you mentioned that diet science is kind
of like built upon a foundation of a
house of cards that it's you can
manipulate data to wield any particular
outcome that you want which can fit a
preconceived ideology
what explain to me someone who doesn't
understand nutrition science how it is
that so many different interpretations
can come from something with the word
science in the name I don't see people
in the physics Community debating over
the speed of light I don't see people in
the chemistry Community debating about
what happens if you add magnesium to
water you know like those seem to be
closed systems the same as our body how
is it that there are so many degrees of
freedom that permit researchers to be
able to do this [ __ ]
yeah well I think it's because nutrition
is a much more difficult science to
study than uh say drug research I
thought you're going to say physics
there the physicists are about to be up
in arms saying it's not rocket science
actually it's nutrition science yeah
well I mean I feel like yeah rocket
science is actually much easier to study
than nutrition Science Nutrition science
is very difficult because people don't
eat single Foods in isolation right they
consume dietary patterns and people
don't consume the same dietary pattern
one decade that they do the next and
people have different needs of course
over the course of their lifespan so
um and different preferences dietary
preferences taste cultural paradigms
that that
um you know nutrition sort of has to
apply itself to
and making matters worse nutrition is
much less well funded right so a lot of
the studies that you'll see for example
showing us the benefits of a food item
like blueberries are actually funded by
the berry board
um which is uh not necessarily a bad
thing right that doesn't invalidate the
science but it's like there's always
going to be there's always a vested
interest
um so you oftentimes will see especially
with more contested food uh categories
like meat right like oh well that study
I'm sure was funded by the beef industry
well you know where else are you going
to find that that kind of money to do
these studies right like you can't
patent broccoli you can't patent an egg
and so there just isn't the kind of uh
commercial interest in it the way that
there is for for drugs and then on top
of that you apply the fact that people
tend to make nutrition their identity
and so there's a lot of ideology within
the world of nutrition right there's a
lot of virtue signaling there's a lot of
um morality brownie points that are
thrown about depending on what dietary
tribe you choose to adopt right and so
um and so yeah so there's What's called
the diet Wars online and I'm just like
I'm I find myself in the middle of it
actually because my the recommendations
that I make tend to be
um among the more balanced of the
recommendations out there so I'm a I'm a
bigger threat to all of the groups right
because I actually present I think what
I think is to be a very balanced message
um
and uh and yeah so it's just uh it's
it's just a big a big problem
um and and the reason why I think it's
so easy for you to spin your message and
to wield science in a way that can
basically
uh prove any point that you're trying to
make ultimately is that like I said
earlier it's sort of like built on a
house of cards like
nutrition science for decades has been
built primarily on epidemiology because
to get human beings to adhere to
long-term multi-center randomized
controlled trials it's just impractical
actually impossible for the most part I
mean we have a few seminal studies like
the pretty Med study which I often evoke
there's the finger study
um which is uh particularly for my sort
of Interest vertical it's the first ever
large population randomized control
trial to look at a dietary intervention
as it applies to cognitive health and
risk for dementia and things like that
but there's just not many of those so
you know you rely for the most part on
on observational types of studies to
make inferences about nutrition and it's
just all so incredibly weak I mean
that's what you find out once you really
get into it
um and you know researchers do their
best to control things for for to
control for example for confounding
aspects of epidemiology like healthy
user bias which
um basically is the uh the the phenomena
whereby somebody who's doing one thing
healthy tends to do other things in
their lifestyle healthy right like like
somebody who is healthy tends to do
healthy things and so you can see that
with people who eat lots of vegetables
fruits and vegetables for example
um but it's the the question that always
arises is the are the is the health of
the of the population that you're
studying due to the item that's being
studied or is it due to all of these
sort of external variables right and so
researchers try their best to account
for all of those things
um but uh but there's this healthy user
buys always Creeps in and a good example
that I like to give is quinoa right if
you were to do like a population level
study of all of the people in the United
States who regularly consume quinoa
chances are they're health is going to
be much better over the long term than
the average person right that doesn't
eat quinoa chances are if a person knows
how to pronounce quinoa right like we
live in a country where the average
reading level is I don't know what third
grade or something ridiculous like that
I don't know don't quit yeah like your
average person does wouldn't know how to
pronounce quinoa right like I think
that's a pretty fair assumption
so if you know how to pronounce it
you're already probably reading Health
blogs or shopping in a supermarket that
carries quinoa right or that lives in a
city where quinoa is available or town
where quinoa is available right so
that's healthy user-wise in a nutshell
if you're eating quinoa you're probably
also eating more whole grains in general
which means you're also probably
consuming more fresh fruits and
vegetables you're probably also more
likely to work out you're less likely to
smoke you're less likely to be sedentary
so is the health of that population due
to the quinoa
or is it in spite of the quinoa or is it
maybe it has nothing at all to do with
the quinoa maybe it's all those other
external variables right that
constellation of other variables that
that um play a role right
in somebody's Ultimate Health and so
when you take fruits and vegetables for
example you see healthy user bias when
you see when you um look at uh
conversely meat consumption in this
country it's well known that people who
who consume more meat tend to smoke more
they tend to be more likely to smoke
they tend to be more likely to be
sedentary and alike so meat always at
the population level it's it's very easy
to find studies that associate meat with
with poor health right but is it because
of the meat itself like if you found
somebody that was eating a paleo diet
for example like a pristine diet with
very high quality food grass-fed
grass-finished meat
you know you likely wouldn't see a
negative Health uh effect from the meat
in fact you probably see a health
benefit and ultimately there are no
long-term randomized control trials to
show that red meat has any negative
effect in fact it's quite the opposite
red meat is uh is a is a wonderful
repository of high quality protein of
carnin nutrients like creatine like
taurine like carnitine like vitamin E
and so um and so yeah I think that we
need to get back to uh like regain a bit
of common sense when it comes to
nutrition and um and unfortunately
Common Sense isn't all that common these
days particularly you know when you look
at all these different diet tribes
you've mentioned that about grass-fed
grass-finished and I imagine that
non-GMO and organic and such like would
be thrown into the mix with that
how big of a deal is it to be someone
that is optimizing for
non-GMO organic grass-fed grass-finished
food how big of an influence does that
make on the on the food profile that
you're eating that's a good question and
this is actually a I think probably
going to be a surprising answer it
doesn't make that big of a difference
um you know there's a lot of uh debate
about organic versus conventional and I
think when it comes to produce the the
big like bang for your buck when it
comes to organic produce is that you're
reducing your exposure to synthetic
petroleum-based pesto pesticides which
are not necessarily getting with
um conventionally produced like with
Organic you're seeing a reduction in
exposure with conventional you're seeing
increased exposure right now the system
isn't perfect the organic uh the way
that organic
um
labeled stuff is produced isn't perfect
like there was a study that came out
recently that found that even organic
wine had
um detectable levels of glyphosate in it
right but uh but I do think that that's
if you are
um if you are wanting to hedge your bets
and adhere to the uh abide by the
precautionary principle which I think um
is smart then organic would be the smart
choice but it's not necessarily more
nutritious than conventionally grown
produce
um you might see higher levels of
various phytochemicals and organic
because these plants essentially
develop uh defense compounds right and
when they are
um doused with these herbicides
pesticides and the like they're the
responsibility the onus is sort of
offloaded from the plants themselves
onto these these external you know
endogenous chemicals exogenous chemicals
that are sprayed onto them and so you
see a reduction in for example
polyphenols
um which could include compounds like
flavonols and flavonoids and and things
like that but we don't really know we
haven't yet Quantified the health
benefit the the you know the sum total
health effect of that when it comes to
vitamins and minerals there's really not
much of a difference and also when it
comes to animal products
uh the differences are also really small
um now in a grass-fed grass finish and
whatever it is colon colon raised corn
finished yeah I mean they're there there
are differences so grass-fed is going to
be a better option for you
um it is healthier part of that has to
do with the fact that uh grass-fed
grass-finished beef is going to be
leaner than conventionally produced beef
so it's going to be more similar to the
kinds of for example Wild game that we
probably evolved uh consuming because
cows are actually not wild creatures we
created cows and the modern cow is a
very fatty animal
um so I do think that there's probably
some benefit to going grass-fed grass
finish if for the fact that it's a it's
a you get a higher proportion of protein
and um less overall fat and in fact you
get a higher proportion of a particular
type of fatty acid called stearic acid
and grass-fed grass-finished beef which
is actually beneficial to health so it's
a saturated fat but it's a beneficial
saturated fat in that it's neutral from
a cardiovascular stem point it actually
has been shown to boost mitochondrial
function you get about five times the
Omega-3s in Grass finished beef as
compared to
uh grain finished beef but those are
that's just a relative increase the
absolute
um the absolute concentration of
Omega-3s and beef is really not that
much right like it's like it actually is
is is quite insignificant compared to
for example wild salmon
um you get about three times the vitamin
E in grass-finished beef
um so it's definitely it's got a
healthier profile for sure but that
doesn't make conventionally produced
beef uh unhealthy right it's still a
great source of protein it's still a
great source of creatine so you know I
like to and because of over the past
decade I've been honed by getting to
reach a wide sort of audience right like
people from across the socioeconomic
Spectrum I don't like to let perfect be
the enemy of the good right so if you're
if you live in a part of the country or
the world where all you have access to
is conventionally produced beef I don't
want people to shun that right because
it's still going to be a better option
for dinner for most people than the
ultra processed option right like the
Box mac and cheese
there's something uh there's definitely
something going on here I can uh imagine
people who are uh avidly non-GMO
enthusiasts saying but what about the
the damages to the chemicals in my body
to the DNA to the to the breakdown of
the telomere length to
there is something I think like sacred
about the way that people feel about
putting stuff into their bodies and when
you have a particular a bias or you've
read something or seen something online
and then you then start to attach your
sense of identity to that it's very
difficult to then drag people back from
it the same person that wouldn't think
twice about eating something that's been
packaged in plastic and left on the
shelf for six months would have a
problem with going GMO because of sort
of some natural I think we saw this as
well with the vaccine right that somehow
the exposure to covid as an infection
risk was more natural than taking the
vaccine and maybe there's an argument to
be made that that could be the case my
point being that as soon as it comes to
putting it in or on your body
there's there's a like a sacredness that
comes to it I think
yeah and I I applaud people who who who
feel that right and I personally like I
buy organic when I'm eating the skin or
the peel of whatever produce it is that
we're talking about and I buy grass-fed
grass-finish beef that's the only type
of beef that I bring into my house I buy
only wild salmon but I also have to
acknowledge that you know I can afford
those things I live in Los Angeles where
I have access to the best supermarkets
in the world right living in Los Angeles
California and so um and so yeah that's
that's that's all like if you have the
ability to to do that then I think that
you absolutely should but again like I
think that you know we can't let perfect
be the enemy the good when people are
especially these days like strapped for
cash right and people live in all
different parts like the people live in
parts of the country that I can't even
imagine right that I'll probably never
get to visit where you know they buy
literally people buy groceries at gas
stations
and so
um and so yeah that that's all
absolutely true that's why I'm a big
believer in what's called a
precautionary principle and I think that
like you know that that's where the data
sort of ends and where your own
principle you mentioned it twice now and
I have no idea what it is so the
precautionary principle is basically
like when we don't have enough data to
to act on something or to uh make a
fully informed decision then we take the
more cautious approach right as of as
opposed to just gung-ho running into the
fire so to speak right I think a lot of
the times you know some of these
newfangled products that we see on the
market whether it's like a food item or
a supplement or a medicine we take the
approach of it being innocent until
proven guilty right that's great for a a
justice system but it's not so great for
when we're deciding what to put into our
bodies right so for me the approach
should instead be guilty until proven
innocent and that's sort of what the
precautionary principle sort of implies
um because we can see many times
throughout history where the food
industry has let us down right has
essentially foisted a product or an
ingredient or whatever onto the human
public only later to have then been
recalled only after serious and
immeasurable damage has been wrought
right a perfect example of that would be
the uh ubiquity up until only about 10
or so years ago of partially
hydrogenated fats right which are trans
fatty acids man-made trans fats fats
that were engineered from vegetable oil
to behave more like saturated fat at
room temperature so they could be used
in Ultra processed foods to replace uh
traditional fats like you know butter
ghee lard and things like that and so
those were on the market for decades
right as the heart healthy alternative
to those more traditional ancestral fats
we later found out that those were
poisonous to the brain to the
cardiovascular system and they were
ultimately outlawed by the FDA but only
after Decades of humans being exposed to
them on a regular near regular basis
right
um other examples lead in our paint
right or lead in our gasoline for that
matter there are compounds that are uh
that we are unwittingly exposed to right
because they are
um
because other Industrial Products have
them in them for example it was recently
shown that Benzene is you could find it
in sunscreen sprays right so we spray
our children with these carcinogens
right every summer when they you know
head out to the beach or the pool
um there was asbestos has been been
found in talc powder so it's just like
the industry has violated our trust
enough times where I think it's
completely reasonable for your average
person or parent to just be a little bit
more skeptical than the media or you
know the evidence-based voices on social
media are are telling them to be you've
mentioned their oils I went to a
bachelor party a couple of months ago
and that there was a bunch of guys that
are pretty deep down the rabbit hole of
no seed oils optimized diet all the rest
of it and we walked through Whole Foods
together and I figured I'm in Whole
Foods you know this is the Pinnacle of
rich white people shopping for food
which is good for them so I I'm like
pointing at different things I'm like
can I have that they're like no can I
have that no can I have that no
everything has estrogen seed oils canola
oil some of the [ __ ] in it
first off what's the problem with seed
oils why are you so anti-seed oil
yeah so see the the debate on seed oils
actually seed oils are having a moment
right now where if you so much as
mentioned seed oils there tends to be a
a gaggle of quote unquote evidence-based
diet Warriors that come after you the
dietitians and the like
and that's because they're I mean
they're controversial because
um
they
do
they're seen as being a heart-healthy
alternative again to these these
traditional ancestral fats
um but they're a novel food so they
haven't been in the food supply prior to
I don't know 60 70 years ago
and humans are now consuming more of
these types of fats than ever before in
human history and just to sort of Define
what seed oils are because I think
sometimes there's confusion about
that the seed oils that that people are
currently talking about are the refined
bleached and deodorized cooking oils
right the industrially processed seed
oils we're not talking about sesame seed
oil which is created just by pressing
sesame seeds the seed oils in question
are the ones that come from for example
soybeans or corn or grape seeds which we
weren't able to produce prior to a
hundred years ago because we didn't have
the the the chemistry
um the the the the chemistry labs and
the Machinery able to extract these from
um their their constituent food items
and then run them through these various
processes to make them palatable because
if you were to extract for example oil
from grape seeds grape seeds used to be
thrown away grapeseed oil is now a
byproduct of wine making and it has to
go through all these steps because it
would otherwise contain noxious
Aromas and flavors and so these are
Ultra processed oils and we know that
Ultra processed oils Ultra processed
foods are defining characteristic of the
modern chronic non-communicable Health
crisis right so for some reason these
seed oils
these industrial refined seed oil is
going to pass by the nutritional and the
medical Orthodoxy
because relative to saturated fats they
will lead to lower levels of
um LDL cholesterol and now I think more
specifically apob which is a sort of
indicator of cardiovascular risk right
and so
these oils being very unsaturated right
you have your saturated fats you have
your unsaturated fats and among your
unsaturated fats you have your
monounsaturated fats and then you have
your polyunsaturated fats
polyunsaturated fats are going to be
more unsaturated than monounsaturated
fats which are a little bit closer to
being saturated and then you have your
saturated fat so it's a little bit of a
chemistry lesson but these
polyunsaturated fats are still loved by
the medical and the nutritional
Orthodoxy because relative saturated
fats they lower LDL which is thought to
be a risk factor for cardiovascular
disease the problem with them
is that they are very prone to a form of
chemical degradation called oxidation so
they go bad they rot essentially you
can't see it it's not this is not a
process that's visible to the naked eye
the same way that when you slice an
apple and you leave it on the counter
and it goes Brown it turns brown that's
like rust that's aging that's Decay
playing out right in front of you in a
way that the naked eye can see you can't
see this happening to grain and Seed
oils but it happens because they're
stripped from the anti the antioxidants
right the chemicals that would otherwise
protect them in their whole food form
they're stripped of those of those
compounds when they're removed from
their whole food form and then they're
run through all these Myriad processes
right some argue that they are processed
using hexane but I wouldn't necessarily
worry about that hexane is a neurotoxin
but they're you know you can't really
find any detectable levels of hexane in
the end product but they're exposed to
very high heat in the production process
one of the steps that they all undergo
is a is a process called deodorization
where they're exposed to very high heat
heat is one of these catalysts of this
oxidative process
and that
damages the oils right it accelerates
its aging process and it also creates
trans fats which we've already
established there's no safe level of
trans fat consumption so you're eating
these
very easily oxidized fats that are
generally already oxidized by the time
you consume them right I mean even if
you were to get fresh oil Straight From
The Jug at your local supermarket
there's a good chance that that a
significant amount of it already has
already undergone this process right but
then you ingest them in restaurants
right like when you eat fried food
where the oil has been sitting in that
fryer for potentially days right
um that that process just it continues
and it continues and it continues and by
the by the end you're eating this like
this mutated fat which contains Trace
levels of trans fats right about five
percent trans fats and these these
oxidation byproducts and what happens is
that those essentially damage you
because you know it's not like sugar
sugar is one of these like sort of
compounds where you know you ingest it
your blood sugar goes up the sugar gets
stored or you use it you know if you're
doing high intensity exercise the fats
that you consume integrate themselves
into essentially who you are they
integrate themselves into your cells
and so this can create over the long
term potentially an inflammatory process
it's not that the oils are acutely
inflammatory but they do provide the
chemicals that are the
precursors to your body's inflammatory
Pathways and so you have all of these
sort of like you have all of this like
kindling laying around in your body
right so it's not that you're like
setting a fire by eating these oils
right like they've actually done studies
you don't see an acute inflammatory
effect when you feed we'll say fresh oil
to a to a human study participant but
you are providing somebody's body
essentially with the kindling necessary
for this inflammatory process and so the
thinking is that and we don't really
have the long-term studies to say this
with certainty so you know there's a bit
of speculation here but again this is a
novel food and I think that you know we
do need to do these kinds of longer term
studies and there's a lack of longer
term
um research that's been done
that uh you're basically you've got the
kindling around for your body's
inflammatory Pathways so that when you
ultimately do encounter an inflammatory
stimulus that you're going to see
essentially an over response right we
also don't know what these uh highly
oxidized products do in the brain over
the long term we have very damning
um animal research we don't quite have
the human data
um although there was a very interesting
randomized control trial in humans that
show that when people
that were prone to migraines which is a
neuroinflammatory phenomena right
migraines you know neuroinflammation is
involved in the migraine process and as
somebody who suffers from migraines
occasionally is this is particularly
relevant to me but this was a really
really important study that found that
when people
um
either increase their consumption of
omega-3 fatty acids which are have the
effect of resolving inflammation or
increase their consumption of omega-3
fatty acids and reduce their consumption
of these vegetable oils these grain and
Seed oils they saw a an improvement in
migraine symptoms but only when they
reduced their
um consumption of vegetable oils so they
saw like a little bit of an effect when
they just ate more Omega-3s but they saw
the biggest the greatest magnitude of
effect when they increased their omega-3
intake but also dramatically reduce
their consumption of vegetable oils
in short seed oil is not good no bueno
yeah now I I don't think they're good I
don't think that they're good and I
think that we have we need to do more
research but you know for for even the
um most the whoever's listening to this
who you know is he who you know thinks
okay well this person that I follow said
said that they're great you know whether
or not that data ultimately reveals
itself to us there's no reason to
consume them because the Mediterranean
dietary pattern which is the dietary
pattern that we know is associated with
robust risk reduction for cardiovascular
disease for neurogenerative disease they
don't consume these vegetable oils they
consume extra virgin olive oil as the
primary oil right there is no long-lived
population on Earth for whom which seed
oils make up a significant calorie
contributor right so you might not
believe that these oils are are harmful
to you and you know I'm always willing
to to adjust my stance when new data
presents itself but there's no reason to
consume them when you have a fat like
extra virgin olive oil available to you
which has all these health benefits
right you can't say the same for these
you know these grain and Seed oils and
humans have been consuming extra virgin
olive oil for Millennia because to make
extra virgin olive oil all you do is you
press olives right same with sesame seed
oil in in Asian population sesame seed
oil has been consumed for Millennia
right it's got all these benefits it's
loaded with vitamin E and compounds
called lignins which might play an
anti-cancer role these Granite oils
they're new foods right so again guilty
until proven innocent they haven't been
proven innocent
you've mentioned a couple of times about
how sort of Novel foods that were not
necessarily used to eating is something
that we should be skeptical of at least
and it seems like the Paleo Community is
sort of really trying to take this and
run with it what is the closest that we
can find to what would have been a
ancestral diet regime and I'll do that
and I'll spend more time in nature and
I'll do CrossFit and whatever
I was with Michaela Peterson this
weekend in Miami and then I was with
safe Dean who is a Bitcoin guy and also
a big carnivore so I've spent
sort of four days basically being
force-fed a rhetoric about uh the
carnivore diet uh now Michaela is kind
of like a I think a bit of a unique case
because her autoimmune disorders are so
chronic and kind of Highly attuned that
a lot of the stuff that she has as
takeaways for her
I'm not convinced are as applicable to
everybody else because she's talking to
a very unique cohort that has all of
these different like whatever
maladaptive properties that of their
physiology safety and on the other side
on the other hand was just somebody that
was doing it because he wanted better uh
cognition he wanted to feel healthier he
was overweight he was blah blah blah and
yet you're saying that we're we're not
carnivores you're saying that an
omnivore approach I noticed that you had
a couple of cups of leafy greens are in
your you must have every single day
approach why are you not a carnivore
yeah because I think a lot of the just
like Michaela and Michael is great we're
we're friends and and I'm completely
sympathetic to her
her learnings you know and and
ultimately her teachings I think that
like you know a lot of the people in the
so-called evidence-based community that
you'll see online tend to be they tend
to be down on what they're not up on I'm
not down on what I'm not up on I'm just
like you know I think that there should
be room at the table for all
perspectives but I think the problem
with the carnivores is that they tend to
it tends to be a cohort for whom you
know many of them suffer from autoimmune
conditions they suffer from digestive
issues and so that's a cohort for whom I
think removing a lot of these whether
it's fodmaps or cellulose or some of
these just not you know difficult to
digest plant material which we're not
you know we don't we don't easily digest
uh I think that's where you'll see uh
reprieve and symptoms right for somebody
who's maladapted to that diet and alas
we live in a time where people have gut
issues right there's widespread
dysbiosis many of us are born via
C-section when there's no medical
necessity to do so sometimes there is
right but oftentimes about that
well you get a bit of a what's what
sometimes referred to as a bacterial
baptism when you're born vaginally right
and there's there's uh lactic acid
bacteria bifidobacterium all there's all
kinds of vaginal flora and and fecal
bacteria that get you know all over the
baby and that sort of provides the the
neonatal immune system with sort of like
the the seeds of what will ultimately
train its immune system right to better
recognize
the difference between self and other
right
and so a lot of is there an issue with
water births if that's the case
uh not I think it's probably a little
bit better
um in water birth although I don't I
don't know for sure but yeah in a water
birth everything is just like in the
water right like in the wash and so
you're just like it's a it's it's a back
to it's it's actually you know it's a
baptism in the more uh colloquial way
that we get a nice big bucket that's
collectible yeah I mean they're now
starting to swab babies uh I don't know
if they're doing this by default but you
know if you're expecting like I think I
think you can ask the physician to to do
this because we're now starting to see
the importance of this sort of bacterial
um you know in induction into uh you
know exposure into these various
different kinds of microbes but it all
comes back to the microbiome like we're
we're recognizing the role that the gut
microbiome and we have a microbiome by
the way everywhere like there are parts
of our bodies that were once thought to
be sterile like mammary tissue for
example or the pancreas that we're now
seeing are teeming with with bacteria
right but when most people refer to the
gut microbiome they're talking about the
community of about 30 trillion
microorganisms that live in the
primarily in the large intestine the
colonic
um
microflora
and
that the that um ecosystem is thought to
really train the immune system the the
majority of your of the immune system in
your body is is primed to focus on
what's happening in and around the gut
because the gut is actually your largest
interface with the outside world you
might be inclined to think that it was
your skin right your skin is a pretty
tight barrier between the inner contents
of your body right and the outside world
but your Lumen your digestive Lumen
which is basically the tube that begins
at your mouth and ends at your anus
right like that's actually that's
actually your largest interface with the
environment if you were to take out the
elementary canal and and like spread it
out it would take up the uh area of a
studio apartment
if not larger than that right so that's
actually a much larger interface with
the external environment and you can eat
you know I mean we were we've evolved
eating like dirty produce right like are
the our ancient world was a lot less
sterile than it has become and in fact
you know you can look to the hygiene
hypothesis which provides a sort of
framework for understanding why we're
seeing such soaring rates
um especially relative to uh to
historically rates of allergies and
autoimmune conditions and the like and
Michaela suffers from an autoimmune
condition or multiple right and a lot of
people that are that are seeing a
reprieve of of their symptomology
um on the carnivore diet have like these
autoimmune conditions right and so it's
the microbiome really is there to train
the immune system but when we're born
whether it's via C-section
or
um we're not uh breastfed breastfed
which provides another sort of way of
strengthening the neonatal immune system
or we over consume antibiotics When
We're Young which is a time when our
microbiomes are particularly plastic
right we've heard of this concept of
neuroplasticity but we have like
almost like microbiome plasticity our
microbiomes are more plastic early in
life right when they're first forming
um and so there's all these like
different aspects right like our
obsession with sterility with hygiene
um this all I think has become
problematic from the standpoint of the
immune system
and so that's where for for people and
so by the way that's like widespread
right so for so for somebody who has
those kinds of issues I think it makes
sense at a carnivore diet
um would at least provide temporary uh
relief right because you're removing
some of these plant compounds many plant
compounds exhibit what's called
molecular mimicry where they look so
closely like compounds in US cells it's
actually in a way like a plant defense
phenomena but to the
underdeveloped immune system
um it can actually trigger like an
autoimmune reaction right like you can
see that with gliding which is the
proteins in gluten where um somebody who
is uh predisposed to for example celiac
disease
um you'll see this like aggressive
violent almost autoimmune effect uh in
the small intestine people with
autoimmune thyroid condition right
there's like this like uh enzyme in the
thyroid
transglutaminase which actually looks a
lot like
um you know various plant compounds so
yeah so I think that like for some
people the carnivore diet makes sense
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say that it's
because plants are a problem you know
it's not that fiber is the problem it's
that like we have all these other
factors due to Modern Life that are
leading to so many of us having gut
dysbiosis and the like but for the
general population I still think
vegetables are great because if you have
already a degree of robustness right in
the system and then you add this sort of
like hormetic stress like this like sort
of external stress into the system then
you have like a strengthening effect but
you all have to have a baseline level of
strength right to benefit from those
hormetic phytochemicals that so many
people like Michaela seem to do better
without right
so that's sort of like my my long-winded
answer but yeah I think that I think
that fruits and vegetables and granted
the carnivores tend to be more against
vegetables as opposed to fruits
especially these days but I do think
that vegetables
um are beneficial but you know it's not
a one size fits-all recommendation like
you even person to person people who are
tolerant and and will ultimately benefit
for vegetables have to find which are
going to be the most
um well tolerated for them yes I the
fruit and meat diet is something that
I'm hearing more about at the moment
which is basically just a middle finger
to vegetables and carbs it seems to me
like so
what about oxalates I've been warned off
oxalates if you have too many green
vegetables apparently that's a bad thing
yeah that's I mean that's another thing
that I think for most people is a
non-issue I mean first of all
spinach is like the highest right in
oxalates so if you are sensitive and
people who are sensitive are going to
know that they're sensitive whether
they've you know suffered from gout or
whether they're prone to developing
kidney stones dudes what a [ __ ]
medieval disease Jesus Christ
it's me and Henry VII dealing with our
gout I know
I know it's not super common but I mean
generally you you know you know like I
think people with with kidney stones
because there's like this accumulation
of calcium oxalate
um in the kidney
like there's a there are contributing I
think genes to this but for I think for
most people especially if you're not
over consuming raw spinach I just think
it's like a non-issue people will often
point to kale and other dark leafy
greens as being a a source of oxalates
but there's really it's very low like
you're not really getting
a lot in kale for example
um you know so it's I I just think it's
a it's a non-issue right I think that um
the recommendation that I make for
people is uh one to two cups of dark
leafy greens a day which if you actually
think about that that's not a lot of
greens right but researchers out of Rush
University found that people who eat uh
between one and two cups of dark leafy
greens every day have brains that
perform up to 11 years younger
so that study could be attributable to
healthy user bias just to be perfectly
transparent and clear right somebody
who's eating a salad a day like most
people aren't eating any salad right so
if you're eating a salad every single
day I mean generally you're probably a
health conscious person but we know that
dark leafy greens yes they have
you know they might have some
concentration of oxalates but they've
got a lot of good going for them as well
they're one of our most nutrient-dense
Foods you're not going to find a better
source of folate than dark leafy greens
you've got vitamin C and dark leafy
greens you also get really important
phytochemicals like lutein and
zeaxanthin in dark leafy greens there
was a study that found that
plant uh flavonoids right so these are
plant defense compounds that high that
plants that were high in flavonoids
actually led to a boost in bdnf brain
derived neurotrophic Factor right which
supports cognitive health and an
improvement in cognitive function right
they compared it to fruits and
vegetables that were low in flavonoids
they didn't see so they didn't see an
effect right they compared it with the
Baseline diet didn't see an effect it
was only the high contained the high
flavonoid containing fruits and
vegetables that led to this cognitive
boost and dark leafy greens were among
them
if I was trying to design a diet
to make myself think as poorly as
possible to slow my thinking I want to
be muddy I don't want to be able to have
good recall I want my verbal agility to
fall through the floor
what what should I eat yeah I mean I
would I think you just gotta consume the
standard American diet like just toe the
line for the status quo
60 of your calories coming from Ultra
processed foods just over consuming
grain and Seed oils lots of fried foods
refined grain products I mean that's
like really the worst of the worst
minimal fruits and vegetables
um
and then you throw in all the lifestyle
factors on top of it I mean exercise
we're now seeing as medicine for the
brain so if you really want to deprive
the brain and lead and make your brain
suffer you'll be sedentary right a brain
suffers atop a sedentary body but it
thrives above a body that is in motion
right a body that that is that is doing
what bodies are supposed to do right
moving and and did I start nerding out
to you at albrey's place about my new
bike desk that I got did I tell you
about this no but let me tell you let me
[ __ ] red pill you about the black
desk so imagine a static bike kind of
like the one that you'll get in like
Lifetime Fitness or whatever and it's
one of the ones where you're a little
bit more
um sat back and the pedals are out in
front of you and there's a backrest so
you can imagine there's usually handles
down by the sides like this yeah then
place a lifted up uh desk on the top of
it with a thick armrest that you can put
on it's purpose built for this it's
called a exoputic exercise work desk and
what you can do is the seat goes up and
down slides forward and back and then
the backrest has got angle on it then
the desk goes up and down forward and
back and also has tilt on it too so you
can lock yourself into a really nice
posturally a great position it's uh Stu
McGill I sent my photo to Stu Miguel the
number one back mechanic on the planet I
was like is this going to [ __ ] me up he
didn't reply so he I'm gonna guess it's
okay but anyway uh point being
180 accumulated minutes ish of Zone 2
cardio per week is pretty hard to do
like it's really really difficult to do
because Zone 2 sucks for me it's quicker
than a walk and slower than a run so
what am I what am I going to do out and
about the nature thing trying to double
it up with Nature's kind of hard
um also 180 minutes just generally to
add on top of maybe a strength and
training routine there's not a ton of
time left for that however if you have a
bike desk what you can do is you can do
up to
and no higher than moderate difficulty
emails or a little bit of admin like
well if you start pushing yourself into
the creative realm it's not happening or
at least for me I I can't think very
well and then I get frustrated that I'm
not doing my work but I also get
frustrated that I've got to slow my legs
now and I can sit I can sit and happily
just churn out emails for 60 minutes and
I'll have burned 600 to 700 calories and
I'll sit at whatever like 120 130 BPM
and I'll just sit and move away and I
feel great once I get off it like that
I'm posturally I feel fine the seat's
super comfortable uh and it's
three hundred and like 10 bucks or 350
bucks for this thing it's [ __ ] great
I can't believe that more people on on
it and uh I I got myself one as a little
treat this summer treated myself to an
exercise desk
this summer because I it was the choices
between that or uh do a Ben Greenfield
approach and get a
treadmill uh to to stand and walk on but
with that I figured it's going to be
harder for me as I'm moving to actually
be able to type stuff especially if I
was doing admin heavy work uh so yeah I
got that and that's my
um
current solution for uh getting some
extras onto it genius I was going to ask
if you podcast while using it but I
would I guess the noise the noise would
be silent it's a magnetic sound oh yeah
yeah you can tell that I really went
down the rabbit hole of the different
features uh but no it's it is silent
however you could take calls on it
there's something about
I've taken a few calls and I get the
impression that the person I'm on the
call with feels like I'm a bit of a dick
I I think what it the subtext of seeing
somebody sat on an exercise desk whilst
talking to you is this conversation
isn't sufficiently important for me to
hold off my exercise until it's finished
and interesting I I
I'm sure that if you were to actually
quiz somebody about it that's it no of
course it's fine but the emotional
response that we have isn't always
necessarily rationally thought through
so I figure like if it's Audio Only
sweet you can get away with it uh if
it's on video I wouldn't do it emails uh
edits and show notes and and back and
forth the admin bits and [ __ ] perfect uh
so yeah highly highly recommended uh
something else that I've been thinking
about a good bit recently especially
since I had human on earlier this year
is magnesium
you are big magnesium guy
big magnesium guy what should people
look for when it comes to choosing a
magnesium supplement and also a diet
that will contribute to better levels of
magnesium yeah magnesium is super
important it's a cofactor in hundreds
something like three anywhere between
three and 600 enzymatic processes using
the body will rely on magnesium
which means that magnesium is
essentially the rate limiting element
here right in hundreds of processes in
the body that range in their importance
from ATP synthesis so the energetic
currency of cells ATP all the way up to
DNA repair so DNA damage is at the root
of Aging but also
tumorogenesis right so cancer
essentially you can uh chalk up to DNA
damage
um among other things and so magnesium
is one of these things that is so
important and about 50 of the population
under consumes magnesium and yeah it's
fairly easy to find so actually if you
go to the produce section of the
supermarket Anything Green anything that
contains chlorophyll which is a plant
pigment is going to contain magnesium if
you actually go to Google images and
search for chlorophyll and hemoglobin
you'll see that they actually look
almost identical except for at the
center of the hemoglobin molecule you'll
find iron but at the center of the
chlorophyll molecule you see magnesium
so anything green generally is going to
be a good source of uh of magnesium also
almonds are a fantastic source of
magnesium just one handful you get about
25 percent of your daily value for it
dark chocolate is another great source
of it
generally you need about 400 to 500
milligrams of it every single day
that makes magnesium what's called a
macro mineral so unlike uh trait unlike
zinc and copper which are trace minerals
um you only need about you know anywhere
between 2 and 15 milligrams of those uh
magnesium is something that you need
more of almost like sodium you know
sodium is another example of a macro
mineral macro mineral potassium is
another example of a of a macro mineral
and the problem with under consuming
magnesium this was actually an idea
proposed by uh aging scientist Bruce
Ames
who coined What's called the triage
Theory of Aging so I already mentioned
that DNA damage is the root cause of
Aging right so when minerals uh or other
you know vitamins for example are scarce
in the body
they get triaged essentially to the
processes that are more
um important with regard to survival
right so if ATP the generation of energy
right that's a lot more important to
survival than DNA repair which is more
of like a long-term project in the body
right so if you are
um
shorting your body on magnesium
you're probably going to have enough to
create energy right but you're not going
to have enough to create the DNA damage
that's happening on a day-to-day basis
in your brain just due to you write like
like time passing
so magnesium is one of these like
essential supplements that I generally
will take every single day and the kind
that I reach for is magnesium glycinate
um there are other forms of magnesium
magnesium is generally pretty
bioavailable you find you'll find
citrate you'll find magnesium
um carbonate there's also magnesium
three and eight which is thought to
support more directly cognitive Health
but magnesium glycinate I like because
it doesn't have the effect of acting
like a laxative which magnesium citrate
magnesium citrate you take enough of
that you're gonna find yourself in the
bathroom soon after
it draws water into the into the gut
um but magnesium glycinate it's just
magnesium bound to a glycine molecule
and also glycine is something that we
tend to under consume today as well it's
an amino acid which is involved in
metabolic health and and you know we I
think we we pretty dramatically under
consume magnesium especially your
average omnivore
and so when you get magnesium glycinate
or bisc glycinate which is two glycinate
um two glycinate molecules uh you're
basically getting like a double whammy
and um and it's a great source of
magnesium you don't have to take it with
food or anything like that and so that's
generally that's generally like my go-to
it's also a great uh it's important for
like migraine prevention
um
you know this is what like one of these
like uh nutrients that actually there's
like good data on it it's also most
people aren't aware of this but it can
actually help prevent noise induced
hearing loss there have been a number of
studies over the past couple of decades
where they'll use
um people that are like in the Army
right like service men and women who are
exposed to really loud noise on a daily
basis you couldn't expose
um civilians to this degree of noise
because it would be unethical right like
no no IRB no institutional review board
would would let this pass but you take
people that are already due to their
occupations right exposed to really loud
noise so those are the kinds of people
that you can actually like easily enroll
in a clinical trial like this and
they've shown that magnesium
um at a dose around the the level that
I've already described about 400 500
milligrams if I recall correctly
um is a really effective prophylactic
for meaning it can help prevent
noise-induced hearing loss for people
that are exposed to loud noise on a
regular basis so I value my hearing
immensely like I love music is like one
of my favorite things in life right so
when I after like exposure to loud music
or whatever or loud noise like if I if I
go to a concert that night I'm taking
um you know pretty high dose magnesium
just to like offset any of the potential
damage the real front line of hearing
loss
Club promoters right this is who we
really should you want you want me to
give you some nice test subjects for
people that have spent way too much time
in overly loud DJ booths Club promoters
that's me going up and telling the DJ
that he needs to stop playing drum and
bass because there's a fight of the far
side of the club or standing at the back
trying to work out why the lights aren't
moving and I've got my head next to some
huge base bin or whatever it is my
business partner has lost
16 DB off the top end and I think 14 or
10 DB or something off the bottom end of
his hearing thankfully mine's not that
bad but he's got tinnitus he's got a
bunch of other things so I'm going to
guess that it's acts as a prophylactic
it's uh protective but not regenerative
is that right yeah right so it's it's
gone it's gone good sorry Dave it's
you've you can't you can't hear what I'm
saying in any case I don't know why I'm
apologizing yeah I mean we don't have
any data on on it you know any
regenerative potential but um but yeah
no I would take it more as a
prophylactic and be just careful going
forward
what's your issue with mouthwash
oh man mouthwash so mouthwash we talked
a little bit about the the fact that we
have like bacteria everywhere right and
we are just at the very very very tip of
the iceberg in terms of understanding
the role that you know all of you know
whether it's like bacteria or viruses or
fungi even play in our health right like
we are we are essentially super
organisms and the gut microbiome plays a
role so too does our oral microbiome and
about 40 of people in this country
regularly use antiseptic mouthwash which
basically indiscriminately nukes the
bacteria in the mouth right what could
be the harm of this you might say to
yourself well maybe you're mitigating
bad breath maybe you're preventing
cavities the reality is which we're now
starting to see is that there is a whole
host of potential Downstream
consequences that occur when we
routinely nuke the bacteria in our mouth
so it turns out that they're not just
doing bad things occasionally for
certain people right they're actually
also doing good things and so by
regularly using antiseptic mouthwash
what you're doing is you're killing off
bacteria that among other things are
involved in the nitric oxide pathway in
your body so when we consume fruits and
vegetables that contain compounds called
nitrates right so beets for example
beetroot powder is a very popular
fitness supplement dark leafy greens
like arugula particularly rich in
compounds called nitrates right when we
consume nitrates the bacteria in our
mouths as we chew them right the
bacteria on our tongue specifically
um
reduce nitrate to nitrite rather to
nitrate which is then what enters this
nitric oxide pathway and nitric oxide is
a gas that we create in our blood
vessels that increases blood flow
reduces blood pressure
and acts as a signaling molecule so it's
also involved in insulin signaling it's
involved in insulin sensitivity which we
know is a really crucial
characteristic of metabolic Health right
and so when you nuke that bacteria
you're basically
disallowing the bacteria or you're
basically negating your ability to
derive a cardio protective effect of
healthy foods fruits and vegetables that
you're eating like beets or dark leafy
greens because you're you're basically
handicapping your ability to generate
nitrite
and so they've done studies that have
found now these are not perfect studies
the Baseline health of the study
participants not that great obese
participants but what they found was
that
um obese participants that uh regularly
used frequently rather used uh
antiseptic mouthwash so this is two
times or more per day
we're at Double the odds of developing
um
hypertension and if and they saw a 50
increased risk of developing type 2
diabetes right
so the hypertension thing makes perfect
sense because as we established this
these nitric oxide
um
supporting bacteria play a role in
helping to reduce blood pressure
and those studies are correlational so
they don't establish causation
um but there was another study that came
out that was a little bit more telling
so this was a randomized control trial
that found that when people in the
post-exercise window so one of the many
benefits of exercise is that it has an
anti-hypertensive effect meaning it
helps to normalize your blood pressure
right it helps to bring your blood keep
your blood pressure in a nice and
healthy range which we know like having
healthy blood pressure is crucial for
having a healthy brain I mean it's it's
healthy for it's it's important for many
reasons but we know that the brain
relies on on healthy blood pressure
right and exercise is one of the best
ways to keep your blood pressure nice
and healthy so what this randomized
control trial found was that
when people swished with antiseptic
mouthwash uh in the post-workout window
they basically negated the
antihypertensive effects uh the
anti-hypertensive effect of that workout
right so typically after a workout you
see this drop in blood pressure over
time and the people the the participants
who swish with antiseptic mouthwash
they didn't see the benefit they didn't
see that benefit
and in this study a type of mouthwash
that's typically um prescription was
used it was called chlorhexidine so it's
not necessarily reflective of what you
might see with um you know one of these
like uh commercially available
um
yeah but I mean you look on the bottle
of like that brand for example and it
says kills 99 of bacteria that's not a
good thing
you know and it's well known that people
with type 2 diabetes are at increased
risk of periodontal disease
right but it's also that you know people
people with periodontal disease with
with dysregulated oral microbiomes are
likely you know that is you know that
it's it's likely a bi-directional
relationship right and so I think
advertising this is something that's
like somehow good for for diabetics it's
a it's a it's a big problem and I think
probably
um pretty harmful so we do need to do
more research on this but yeah I mean
mouthwash is something that like if
unless you're using it for medical
reasons I would say stay away from it
you know if you if you use it now and
then that's totally fine but if you're
one of these like frequent users two or
more times a day
um that's definitely a habit worth
changing you also mentioned earlier on
the dangers associated with certain
types of sun cream maybe all types of
sun cream
what do I do if I want to be out in the
sun and I don't want to get burnt
so I think it just comes back to
developing a healthy relationship with
the sun and you know going back to the
to the mouthwash thing
you know there are a lot of um practices
that are have been um or like
uh paradigms that have been sort of put
into place by our Public Health
officials that
I guess made sense when they were
instituted at the time right like I can
see how fluoride in the drinking water
serves a public health
good because
of the fact that so many people today
are over consuming Ultra processed foods
refined grain products that easily gets
retained by Oral bacteria and so that's
why you see widespread dental decay
right and so like but like it's we're
not seeing widespread dental decay
because of like a lack of fluoride right
if you actually eat a biologically
appropriate diet you're not going to
need the mouthwash you're not going to
need the fluoride in your toothpaste
right
um and obviously people have different
like genetic like Tendencies to develop
um you know cavities and the like not
everybody's the same but um but the same
goes with the sun like we've been told
that there's no safe level of sun
exposure but the sun is crucially
important the sun is medicine in many
ways I mean the sun actually directly on
our skin helps to create nitric oxide
right it's the UVA rays that actually
acts like a hormetic stressor on our
skin and just under the surface creates
nitric oxide which is important for
lowering blood pressure right it's also
well established that exposure to the
UVB rays from the Sun help us to
synthesize vitamin D which is a steroid
hormone responsible for
regulating about five percent of the
human genome right it's important for
cognitive function it's important for
our healthy immune function and down
regulating uh an overactive immune
system so there's actually really
compelling data on the role of vitamin D
in quieting um autoimmunity in the body
Ms in particular there's a you know
vitamin D is like one of the only
vitamins that has a relevant clinical
impact on multiple sclerosis right and
we get vitamin D for the most part from
the sun it's also crucially important to
Anchor our body's circadian rhythm we
know that every organ system is
responsive to
um to cues about what time of day it is
and the Sun is the chief light bright
light in particular is the primary time
center for the human brain
so yeah if you're going to spend time in
the sun I think the way to do it is to
gradually
um ramp up your sun exposure and to not
burn right but like I think by eating a
healthful diet
um you're gonna have some degree of
protection uh against this you know
probably more so than somebody who's on
like the standard American diet but you
have to be you have to like develop a
responsible relationship with the sun
right like you don't want to just sit
out all day
um
and burn there's actually no reason to
we generate more vitamin D it's more
effective to uh
have like smaller increment doses of Sun
as opposed to for example the phenomena
whereby like you spend no time in the
Sun and then you go on vacation and you
just you know from one day to the next
you're spending zero time in the sun to
spending four hours five hours in direct
sunlight that is not good for your skin
it's not good for your health and it's
not an effective way of producing
vitamin D the more effective way of
producing vitamin D is to actually spend
uh small like lesser amounts of time in
the Sun but on a daily basis
so this whole notion that like the sun
is bad for you there's no safe level of
sun exposure
yeah it's pseudoscience
is there any safe way to put something
on your skin as a lotion or a topical
solution of some kind that can help to
mitigate exposure to the Sun
I'm going to watch a
baseball match which I've learned can
sometimes take like four hours in this
country and it's going to be in the
middle of the day in the middle of the
summer and I'm gonna get exposed to the
Sun and I can wear a long sleeve top and
I can do all the rest of it but my face
is going to be in the Sun or whatever
else there are certain situations in
which people can't avoid sun exposure
and haven't had time to build up a
month's worth of 30 minutes in the
morning and 30 minutes in the evening of
sun exposure to get them a base tan what
should they do then yeah I mean you're
absolutely right I am a fan of some
black some black in the appropriate
context and the sunblock that I think is
the best to use are the mineral-based
sunscreens like
um because they're actually sunscreens
they're they provide a physical barrier
between your skin and the Sun so zinc
oxide titanium oxide I believe uh those
are the two primary ones you generally
want to steer clear from the chemical
based sunscreens the in the industrial
the the synthetic industrially produced
um sunscreens like the oxybenzones and
the Avo Ben zones
um now if I'm desperate uh it's better
to use those I think
um you know on an infrequent basis than
to burn just to be super clear
um but you know we're now seeing that
those actually are easily able to enter
uh circulation so that they they do
um we do absorb them
um and new data is starting to show us
that we absorb them at uh alarming rates
and at a concentration that we actually
don't really have a sort of full picture
on the data of with regard to how they
affect our biologies there was a an
alarming paper that came out that showed
that um you know if you use sunscreen
in a level that is typical right you
slather your body with it it actually
um absorbs into circulation and reaches
a level that surpasses the fda's
threshold of toxological concern so this
is something that we don't know like the
long term and I'm not gonna I'm you know
it's probably not good right like what
what these compounds are doing in us
um when when used chronically and over
the long term particularly if you are
um a child right if you're still
developing because many of these
compounds have exhibited uh endocrine
disrupting
um abilities right so the ability to
scramble your hormones avobenzone
oxybenzone these are well established
endocrine disruptors and if all they did
was stay on the surface of your skin you
know I think the concern would be
um a little bit sort of less but now we
see that they they easily enter
circulation so I would um definitely opt
for the more the more mineral-based ones
um which uh I don't think there's that
that level of of concern another thing
that you could do
um and this isn't going to be as
effective as using sunscreen if you're
you know exposed to the sun in broad
daylight
um in one of these high UV areas of the
world but uh astaxanthin is actually a
compound that's found in wild salmon and
you can supplement with it and it's sort
of like an internal sunblock
um they've they've done studies where
they've shown that um that there is a
degree of photo protection provided by
astaxanthin which is this compound that
is created so so wild salmon it's what
gives wild salmon its characteristic red
Hue but the salmon aren't born with that
color they actually get it when they
consume algae and algae sit at the top
of the water surface right exposed to
the harmful you know radiating rays of
the Sun
all day long right algae can't like swim
away they can't put like a t-shirt on
they can't move into the shade I will so
what we do they generate this super
powerful antioxidant called astaxanthin
which is like specifically designed to
protect them from the sun's rays and
that's why they've done these clinical
studies to see well what are they what
can this compound potentially do in us
right and they found that aside from
protecting Eye Health and from uh
improving skin appearance right
it actually can also uh provide some
degree of of skin protection so I'm a
huge fan of Astaxanthin it's another one
of like these staple supplements that
I've been saying I've been taking
acetamine for about 15 years at this
point
um really really good data on it
and I was in Zambia filming a mini
documentary a couple of weeks ago and I
learned how easily hippos burn uh which
you might not be familiar with
apparently really susceptible to the Sun
and they they get they get all pink on
the top of the on their heads and on the
little snouts they got all pink and they
get burned if they get caught out in the
sun which is bad for them uh all right
so you've mentioned their Aster xanthin
are there any other supplements that you
take that you consider a staple of your
routine uh that would not be
common or that you think that people
should be uh more aware of I should have
a look at huh
yeah I mean I think like fish oil is
fairly common but I'm I'm pretty uh
religious about my fish oil
supplementation regimen I take about a
gram I've heard that there are certain
types of fish oils that you do want and
certain that you don't do you want the
ones that smell fishy or the ones that
don't smell fishy after you've had them
you are the ones that don't smell fishy
and actually one thing that I do is I
actually chew occasionally the fish oil
especially if I'm buying like a new
bottle like a fresh bottle I'll chew it
which um a lot of people you know
listening probably gonna be like that's
gross Max but
fresh fish oil if it hasn't gone bad
actually shouldn't have any overt fishy
flavor and so um because you know like
fresh fish doesn't stink it's only like
if you walk through a fish market it's
all the dried oxidized fish oils that
um you know residues that are still
lingering that's what stinks right but
fresh oil fresh fish oil shouldn't have
any discernible maybe like very slight
but it shouldn't have any discernible
um brand that you use a fish oil
I mean I've been using uh Nordic
Naturals for years I have no no
affiliation with them
um so I don't work with them you know I
I think in the past I did like do a
little bit of like you know because I
have my own podcast it's called the
Genius life I I think I have worked with
them in the past but I'm not currently I
just generally like I go to Whole Foods
and I buy it with my own money
um because they they just taste the
freshest to me you know you could also
smell the bottle like that's another
good thing to do smell the bottle it
shouldn't smell overtly fishy you're
gonna get like a slight I think probably
um odor but uh and that's not the only
good brand you can one good thing to
look for on fish oil bottles is iPhones
ifos it's the international fish oil
standards
um it's this uh third-party independent
organization that routinely tests fish
oil for oxidation and oxidation
um byproducts so it's it's sort of a way
of um you know it's just like one more
sort of Notch on the belt of of knowing
that the fish oil that you're getting is
of sufficient quality that they've been
able to sort of afford uh to submit you
know for testing that the ifos got
behind it so again it's like not
associated with any of these like fish
oil brands but you'll see it on some on
some Brands I think a Whole Foods brand
itself actually is ifo certified okay so
no astaxanthin fish oils make sure that
they are of a good quality and don't
smell too fishy what else yeah uh I take
creatine I take creatine not um I'm an
omnivore so I wouldn't expect to get a
cognitive benefit from it although
people who are not omnivores people who
are vegan and vegetarian there's some
data that suggests that creatine
supplementation can actually lead to a
cognitive boost creatine is a compound
that's naturally found in muscle meat
um
and organ Meats to some degree but you
primarily get it in muscle meat and so
you ingest enough of it as an omnivore
to provide the brain with all of the
sort of exogenous creatine that it needs
um but uh but they've done
um there's one or two studies that have
that have that the signal was that
creatine supplementation can actually
boost cognitive function and people who
don't regularly consume meat but I take
it I take about five grams a day it's a
it's a there's a robust safety wreck
record and efficacy record for creatine
as a ergogenic compound meaning it helps
to support physical performance
um and I think I think it's a great
supplement for both men and women it
might lead to a very slight weight gain
but it draws muscle it draws water in
intramuscularly so it's not like you're
not going to see puffiness it's like
water that's like literally like in your
muscles
um and it helps to boost uh energy
essentially in the gym
which can then lead to you know
long-term strength gains and the like so
I think it's a great supplement don't
take it without checking with your
doctor first if you have a medical
condition
um you always want to check with your
with your physician before you know
adopting any new supplement but
generally I think creatine is a good one
I also I think uh protein powder is
great I'm a big fan of whey protein whey
protein is very high biological value
it's a great source of leucine and other
essential amino acids lutein in
particular is leucine rather is is very
important for simulating muscle protein
synthesis but it you know of course
comes with the whole complex of
essential aminos it's also um
a rich source of cysteine which can help
support glutathione synthesis so there's
actually a role for whey protein for
supporting immune function which is is
really important helps to promote the
synthesis of glutathione which is your
body's Master antioxidant
um so I'm a huge fan of whey protein I
think I mean I think protein is one of
these macronutrients it's like
um almost magical in the in the for what
it does to the human body right like
it's
it supports your musculature and muscle
and strength is really in many ways the
currency of longevity so you want to
support your musculature and whey
protein protein in general is a great
way to do that
a great way to do that no pun intended
um
it's a
you know it's it's the most satiating
macronutrient
um much more so than carbs and fat you
can look to the protein leverage
hypothesis like we we definitely like
you know in many ways it seems our
hunger our drive to eat is driven by our
necessity for amino acids and and and
you know protein more generally uh and
actually protein also
drives up levels of glp-1 a lot of
people these days are talking about
semi-glutide which is a glp-1 Agonist
it's uh it's been hailed as a
revolutionary weight loss drug it's
prescribed for helping better manage
blood sugar
um and one of the reasons why it's so
effective for weight loss is that it's
very it reduces appetite it slows
Transit it slows what's called gastric
emptying so the transitives of uh the
contents of the stomach into the small
intestine
um it also boosts insulin sensitivity
um or rather it boosts it uh releases it
causes a release of insulin
um
and so you've got this like
revolutionary right like weight loss
drug some glue type but actually you can
boost glp1 Yourself by just prioritizing
protein in your diet and so that's one
of the one of the many reasons why I
think people who even incrementally
increase their protein consumption will
see a
a degree of body recomposition right
less fat Mass greater lean mass so
protein is yeah protein is where it's at
on top of those one thing that I've
found that's interesting at the moment I
think even Ben Greenfield both seem to
agree on this is that the healthy
Community the fitness community that are
kind of considering what 20 years ago
would have been revolutionary you know
making sure that they're getting
sufficient protein in making sure that
they're doing some sort of strength and
weight training protocol even if you're
a woman who's not looking to get much
more muscular focusing on sleep ensuring
that they've got proper sleep hygiene
both of you seem to be kind of taking
recommendations for Fitness not into a
more complex uh realm but certainly
Beyond just that
um if you were looking at what you
consider to be sort of the typical
Fitness crowd at the moment what are the
habits that you think that they are
missing mostly that they're probably not
thinking about at the moment
well I think the typical Fitness crowd
is uh tends to be obsessed well there
there tends to be a lot of obsession
within um the fitness Community a lot of
like body image issues
um a lot of fractured relationships with
food that's just my observation and I
don't actually consider myself part of
the fitness Community maybe because I
didn't come from a personal training
background or uh
um
I'm not a bodybuilder I'm not an athlete
I'm not a power lifter I like I've been
I've always been interested in
bodybuilding but
um
but you know I think that like I am
versed in I'm versed enough in Fitness
uh and and nutrition science but with
sort of one foot also in the world of
longevity where I can sort of like
filter the the
what the data says about how to best for
example
um lose fat or gain muscle through the
lens of like okay well what's also going
to be best for like my long-term Health
like the long game right there's this
concept that I've become kind of
interested in
that is uh it's a fascinating concept
and it's like it's a very unfortunate
phrase
um it's antagonistic pleiotropy it's
just it's a it's a mouthful and it's
like it's not something it's not sexy
it's like not what's something that your
average person is going to remember but
it's a very powerful
um concept and uh it basically is like
the things that are good for us you know
as we're developing and as we are uh
approaching
Peak reproductive
shape right like to be in like our our
strongest and most uh you know robust
physical form aren't necessarily also
going to be what's going to get us to
the age of 100 or the age of you know
120 for that matter right and so I think
it's a really interesting thought
experiment to try to reconcile like okay
well what if we did want to do both what
if we did want to get into like
Ben Greenfield shape for example right
but also like have our bodies in
fighting form when we're also like 80
and 90 and 100 and I feel like sometimes
like you've got like the world of
longevity and you've got the world of
Fitness they don't they don't they're
kind of like siled off right but I'm I'm
actually very interested in like
bridging that divide and reconciling
um those two sort of like seemingly
Divergent ideas and so you know one
thing that I think is really important
that people in the fitness industry
don't really talk about very much is
like the value of food quality right
like I mean I I see so many people in
the world of fitness
boiling it all down to calories in
calories out and calories yeah they
matter right but like they're not all
that matter like food quality I think
plays a major role and especially for
somebody who's
scratching their head wondering why diet
after diet seems to fail for them I
think it's really important that people
know that food quality in many ways
dictates the quantity of food that one
is inclined to consume right there was
this really great seminal study that was
performed in 2018
funded by the NIH Kevin Hall Ledet who's
a well-known obesity researcher who
found that when people were given access
only to ultra processed foods they
tended to over consume
um their energy requirements for the day
by about 500 calories that's a 500
calorie essentially in other words
energy Surplus that they consumed when
just eating two satiety right like
eating to a point where they felt like
okay I could walk away from the table
now
this was a crossover trial so then what
the researchers did was they gave them
access to a diet that was less processed
right like a minimally processed diet
like the kinds of foods that you might
find around the perimeter of the
supermarket as opposed to in the aisles
of the supermarket when they found what
they found was that when eating to the
same degree of satiety right like I've
had enough I'm good
the subjects ended up eating
at a 300 calorie food calorie deficit so
that right there that's an 800 calorie
swing determined not by somebody
counting calories in there in an Excel
spreadsheet or with an app right that
was determined purely by the quality of
the food that they're consuming so
oftentimes a lot of people when their
diets fail they tend to feel a sense of
moral failure like why couldn't I just
count my calories you know more
rigorously or you know why did I over
consume the pint of ice cream I intended
only to have one scoop and you know
before I knew it I was looking at the
bottom of the Pint well it's because
that food quality in many ways dictates
the quantity of the food that you feel
compelled to consume right when you're
when you're basing your diet on
higher protein foods on foods that are
more minimally processed maybe it's like
because you eat them more slowly than
something that's more uh refined right
that you have this um release of
hormones right like glp-1 for example
that uh that makes you less inclined to
overeat and I think that's like
something that you don't often get in
the in the fitness community that tends
to make things all about calories right
it's just like calories in calories out
is a mathematical Maxim like like it's a
platitude that yeah it's true calories
in calories out the the the key to Fat
Loss is is being in a calorie deficit
but where it fails is that it's really
shitty advice it's just not good advice
and that's what your average person is
also it's also that advice
is exactly the advice that the food
industry wants people to be giving out
as well because you know with that
advice there's no such thing as a good
or bad food right like you can have it's
like you can have the the soda you can
have the like the ice cream it's not our
fault that you didn't moderate your
consumption of the ice cream you fat pig
right it's your fault but that's because
people are not awake they're not being
told that these foods are not designed
to be consumed in moderation right so I
didn't mean to Fat shame right there
that's not the intent the intent was to
say that that's that's how the food
industry thinks of you right that if you
weren't able to lose weight because on
on this sort of like calorie-centric
approach you know to weight loss you
weren't able to just eat less and move
more it's your fault you know that was a
moral failure on your part but that's
not true that's not the case the case is
that we live in a toxic food environment
a food environment that you know Ultra
processed foods are omnipresent they're
always at our Arms Reach
and and they're designed to be hyper
palatable they're designed to push your
brain to a bliss Point Beyond which
self-control is
essentially impossible right and granted
there is variation here some people will
be better able to moderate their
consumption of ice cream and some people
can't people have their different
trigger foods right like
but um but I think like talking about
the the behavioral aspects of food and
the relationship that we have with food
I think that's crucially important way
more important for the long-term
sustainability of one's sort of Fitness
lifestyle than the more calorie-centric
approach which tends to be parroted by
people in the fitness community over and
over and over and over again yeah well
I'm good friends with James Smith and
during cartel and both of them are that
miss the calories both of them yeah like
the calorie couple uh and they're right
like the fundamentals of weight loss
when it comes down to the thermodynamic
uh sort of underpinnings of it all
calories in and calories out but the
means by which you get there it seems to
be what you're saying Mata an awful lot
it's like do you want to swim upstream
or do you want to swim Downstream when
you're trying to control the calories
that you eat and then on top of that you
know the If It Fits your Macros bro
lifestyle that me and all of my lifting
friends were a part of 15 years ago like
when that first came on the scene it was
phenomenal because you could cut and eat
Haribo they couldn't eat many Haribo you
couldn't have much cheesecake but you
could it it basically told you that as
long as you hit these three numbers by
the end of the day
Nothing Else Matters it's like all that
you're bothered about your
macronutrients by the end of it and it's
any calories bro is what is the solution
but that definitely led to a bunch of
disordered eating from me because I
never I never learned the value of
padding out a meal with a [ __ ] ton of
vegetables like okay like I could have
my carbs come from these four or five
pieces of Haribo
or I could have like two sweet potatoes
and it would be the same it's the same
in terms of the the very narrow view
that I'm having of how many carbs are in
it probably gonna end up being the same
something similar uh
and yet the experience of eating it and
my subsequent uh sense of hunger
is wildly different and then that's
before even talking about micronutrients
minerals fiber all the rest of the stuff
um so yeah I I think that
short and snappy tag lines are always
going to be sexy because they help to
minimize down something that's by its
nature kind of complex into something
which is really uh really simple and
easy to understand but
um a lot Gets Lost in Translation I
think yeah and and again I think that
there's a seat at the table for all of
the different perspectives and I've seen
some of James's content I think he's
he's phenomenal you know but like I
think you also have to understand
context and where these people are
coming from like and you and you know I
think like many of them who in the past
have come after me need to understand
where I'm coming from right like these
are people who are like Fitness
professionals and and you know they have
a certain kind of experience right A lot
of people that gravitate towards that
content these are people that are
already very obsessed with their bodies
right and they're they're amenable to to
constantly tracking things like that
right I'm I'm more thinking of it from
like a public health standpoint
um and also I've been honed by my
experience of getting to reach like
people yeah I reach a lot of Fitness
Bros on social media right but I also
you know I've been able to do a lot of
like television in the United States
where I reach people that are not on
Instagram you know that are that are not
obsessed with Fitness they're just like
obese overweight and they have no idea
why
you know so like for me I think you've
got to yeah yeah you have to talk about
calories like calories definitely play a
role but you can't I don't think that
you can really lead with that
um I think we have to talk about the
behavioral aspects of food and and
because like once you plant the seed of
knowledge I think that that generally
for the motivated
person right
is going to then be be able to like
adopt behavioral change and create
healthy new habits for themselves right
like you know
eating while distracted right like
watching watching TV like if you're if
you're eating while you're watching TV
or you know reading a magazine for
example or scrolling through your phone
you're going to be inclined to consume
about 15 more calories than if you're
just like present with your food
and so over the long term that is gonna
add up quite fast in fact right so you
know like be more present with your food
don't just eat mindlessly on the go like
that's another thing that I think can
really help people right
um there was a study recently that
looked at uh people who ate late at
night like late night eating compared to
early time restricted feeding this is a
super controversial area right people
are like you know it's sort of
intermittent fasting and and
um you know you see the calories in
calories out of people saying like it
does intermittent fasting doesn't do
anything it's all about Seco well yeah
it at the end of the day it is about
calories and calories out but this study
what was so interesting about it was
that it found that people who eat who
ate late dinner dinner late at night at
about 9 pm compared to people who
um it actually might have been a
crossover trial so where you know
subject participants were sort of like
their own controls
uh what they found was that late night
eating led to uh increased hunger the
next day
um increased hunger the next day people
were more inclined to they consumed
about 60 more calories and they saw a
reduction in their resting metabolic
rate by I believe about five percent why
would that be the case
well it's just that like hunger is
driven by hormones and hormones are
influenced by our circadian biology like
this is now what we're starting to see
right so this doesn't work typically
though when it comes to an intermittent
fast most people that do it David
Sinclair and you Alex Friedman's of the
world will Fast through the morning
and eat later in the day I see very few
people proposing an intermittent fasting
regime which involves eating upon waking
and then fasting for the from the 4 P.M
slot until eight in the morning
so the data is actually coming out uh
suggesting that that sort of late start
and followed by a late dinner is
actually the wrong approach we're we're
diurnal creatures so we're meant to eat
during the day I'm not saying that we
need to eat as soon as we wake up right
um but we're meant to eat sometimes
shortly after we after we arise I think
like when intermittent fasting first
came on the scene scene so to speak
um people didn't think it really
mattered so much like where you placed
that feeding window whether it was 12 to
8 or 2 to 10 but what we're now starting
to see is that our metabolic furnace is
primed to digest and metabolize food you
know when it's light out because when
the Sun goes down that's really when our
ancestors would have kind of winded down
and got them gotten themselves ready for
bed right you also don't need as much
energy late at night you're just not
doing as much stuff late at night but
now due to the you know the ubiquity of
artificial lighting the like we you know
we're sort of constantly in this like
sort of Vegas
environment where you know our brains
don't really have a good sense of what
time of day it is but ancestrally
we would have probably been foraging
um and eating uh generally when the sun
was up and for maybe you know some short
time after the sun went down
but this whole notion that like eating
late at night is somehow like
biologically appropriate that's a very
modern phenomena I mean today we're
eating 16 hours a day your average adult
is consuming and metabolizing food 16
hours a day you know which is like the
entire time that they're waking up
actually they're they're digesting food
probably even longer than that right
because you're you're if you're eat
right before you go to bed then you're
actually digesting while your body
should be like priming itself for the
restorative and reparative processes
that occur during sleep not metabolizing
not digesting and metabolizing your food
right so what the studies are now
starting to show is that early time
restricted feeding so people can
actually go to go to PubMed and look
this up it's sometimes abbreviated in
the in the medical literature as etrf
an acronym that stands for early time
restricted feeding what we're seeing is
that early time restricted feeding
compared to late time restricted feeding
actually actually
um coincides with a number of cardio
metabolic benefits so it's not that you
know something that you eat at 10 pm has
more calories than if you were to eat it
at 6 PM that's not the case it doesn't
again it doesn't refute calories and
calories out
but it seems to be the case that eating
uh late at night can lead to well next
day hunger as I as I already mentioned
uh reduction in resting metabolic rates
small but
um you know but they they were able to
see this in a in a trial hormone
dysregulation so various hormones that
are involved in satiety and hunger and
um metabolism like leptin and ghrelin
were uh were dysregulated
but then also blood sugar regulation and
blood pressure are affected by late
night eating it seems
what you eat still trumps when you eat
but I mean say you can't or don't want
to change what it is that you're eating
right this is a modification that you
might potentially make that could over
the long term
um have a you know have a positive
effect on your health
so yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't push the
eating because I used to do this I used
to like not eat my first calorie until
like you know like 2 p.m or something
ridiculous like that now generally I
wake up at around seven or eight a.m and
I'll eat at around
you know 10 or 11
um am and I try to on my best days not
eat too late after uh 7 P.M that doesn't
always happen you know dinner today is
our most social meal so I think it's
important that people don't get dogmatic
about this
um
you know you don't want to go you don't
want to forego social opportunities
um in the name of early time restricted
feeding but uh but there is a signal
there like in the medical literature
that I think is like worth worth
listening to for sure dude a lot of
things I think to throw out of the
window at the moment maybe my uh again
Club promotion career that I was doing
where I would finish finish at three in
the morning and come home and eat the
food that I'd prepared earlier on at 4am
uh might contribute to a little bit of
The Hunger that I was having and also
the the mouthwash thing for me is is
huge I've been an avid mouthwash user
thinking that I was doing something good
for my dental hygiene that turns out
might not be quite so good for my body
overall and look dude let's bring this
one home I appreciate the [ __ ] out of
you I really love your work where should
people go if they want to check out the
things that you do and the books that
you've got and all the rest of it you're
the man thanks Chris well I have my own
YouTube channel youtube.com
maxlugavier uh where
um you know I put up a lot of my content
I have a podcast called the Genius life
um I've written three books now uh
genius Foods is my first book which is a
New York Times bestseller it's like a
deep dive it's like a nutritional care
manual for the human brain so I highly
recommend people check that out or you
know if you like to cook I put out a
cookbook called genius kitchen
and then I'm super active on Instagram
so but I'm easy to find so you know come
and find me all right man cheers what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]